you know when I was young I grew up
watching Star Trek I used to dream about
tricorders replicators you know these
transporters all these amazing advances
we we saw I also imagined that be using
communicators that I'd have a replicator
reproducing all the ice cream and
chocolate that I wanted so I used to
imagine a world of amazing things and we
had solved the problems of humanity we
was shooting for the stars when we're
exploring new worlds that's how I
thought it would be when I grew up look
at the ones I grew up into poverty
hunger despair where we put each other
down we were worried about scarcity
running out of resources it's the exact
opposite of what I thought we would have
when I grew up when I was young so I
like the rest of the world became
pessimistic you mean two or three years
ago
I too was worried about shortages of
energy food hunger overpopulation the
world you know coming apart because of
all of these battles were fighting if
you read my writing right now I'm the
greatest often mister is I talked about
this being the most innovative decade in
human history when we saw the Grand
Challenges of humanity I talked about
the Star Trek future we're headed into
what changed over there what changed was
that I started learning about the
advances that are happening in
technology in hanging out with people
like Peter Diamandis and reycarts well
at singularity University I started
learning about the fact that computing
is moving exponentially and it's causing
many other fields to go exponential we
all know about Moore's Law and we've
seen how computers advanced in in
capabilities indeed our smartphones are
more powerful than the query
supercomputers of yesteryear the same
advances are now happening in 3d
printing in artificial intelligence
robotics synthetic biology in medicine
and what they're making possible is for
us to solve the Grand Challenges of
humanity you know III now believe that
within the next ten to twenty to thirty
years we're gonna have unlimited energy
solar is advancing most predictably but
there'll be many other technologies that
do that become viable over the next five
or ten years which means that in the
2025 2030 times
we should be an era of almost unlimited
energy we'll have solar cells or other
technologies which generates energy
locally and which let us power electric
cars which are clean they let us now
produce unlimited clean water we can go
unlimited food we can 3d print meat so
we head into an era when technology is
going to make it possible for us to to
get out of this shortest shortage mode
we've been in as well we'll also have
advances in healthcare well ready here
now have sensor based devices that we
carry in our pockets
they're called smart phones they track
where we go when we sleep they track our
activity levels will also have wearable
devices that monitor our internals and
monitor our vital signs
they'll all be connected to the cloud
we'll have AI based physicians which
monitors on a 24 by 7 basis and tell us
when we're about to get sick they'll
advise us on how to eat better how to
he'll live healthier lifestyles so we'll
be living longer we'll be living
healthier we'll be having an abundance
of the basics we need we were able to 3d
print buildings this is an error we're
headed into and when I finished giving
my talks people start looking more
closely at the things that are happening
reading up and I have most people coming
to me later on weeks after they've heard
my talk about advancing technology and
say you know Vick you really opened our
eyes that it does indeed seem that the
world is headed in the right direction
they're always amazing technology
advances happening which have been a
better mankind now by the way I've also
become really concerned about the dark
side of technology for a while I was
just thinking the world is going to be a
wonderful place it was all good you know
rah rah rah rah rah rah
now after all so started worrying about
the fact that we're creating a dark side
to all this then we could be critic
creating killer viruses that with all
this automation with 3d printing and
robotics we're headed into an era when
women we won't need human beings doing
manufacturing with AI based physicians
we won't need as many doctors we won't
need supermarket clerks
we won't need people doing delivery we
won't need truck drivers we won't need
taxi drivers we're headed into a jobless
future it's almost certain that that
that
Automation now takes away more jobs and
it creates a so it's always been it's
almost certain that we have social
unrest because large parts of the
population have begun unemployed and
they have nothing better to do and they
are not like the rest who want to now
start learning new careers and doing
things it's almost certain that laws and
ethics can't keep pace with advancing
technologies the fact is already having
these battles in the Supreme Court it's
this case about error broadcasting TV
signals went to the Supreme Court and
now we're battling with watching uber
battle the taxi industry we have n be
battling the hotel industry we're having
these new technology companies battling
online industries this is the beginning
we're going to see more and more debates
about what's right and what's wrong the
lost can't keep up because laws are
based on laws are essentially codified
ethics that we develop a consensus as a
society but what's good and what's bad
and then it becomes what's right and
what's wrong and then it becomes what's
legal and what's illegal that's the way
the progression goes on most of those
technologies we haven't decided what's
good or bad is it good to have drones
delivering our goods yeah it'll be
convenient if we can get Starbucks
delivered to our homes in the morning
rather than have him drive down to to
the coffee shop but these drones also
have high-definition cameras in them if
they happen to drop but to fly by your
bathroom and you've got the window open
is it okay for them to be photographing
you is it okay now for these drones to
be carrying weapons what happens if you
had swarm of drones now attacking
buildings so we haven't figured out
what's legal what's illegal what's right
or wrong so we're going to be having
many debates about it so you've got the
optimistic Vivek Wadhwa
who thinks about the amazing world we're
headed into how everything is going to
be wonderful and we will solve the grand
challenge the challenges of humanity and
then you've got this fellow at Stanford
Law School who is researching the ethics
and legal issues of advancing
technologies and this professor is
really worried about the dark side of
Technology and the nightmares that are
being created by the people who
taking these technologies and using them
for bad so it's a very interesting era
we're headed into the only thing that
certain is it change will happen the
only thing a certain is the technologies
will advance the only thing that's
certain is that we would have good and
we will have bad it's really up to us to
decide what we do with it and how we
deal with these advances we can make the
world the Star Trek utopia we dreamed
about or we can make it a Mad Max
madhouse and be killing each other and
you know destroying a matter it's really
up to us so this is why I encourage
students to now start learning ethics
and values and to focus on bettering the
world because it's really up to us what
we do with it we need more people now
focused on the betterment of humanity on
using technology for good versus evil so
we can balance out the bad will always
be there we just have to have more
people doing good and uplifting humanity
if we do that we can have this amazing
you know your toe peein world we that we
watched on on Star Trek where we fix the
part of the humanity we're now going to
new lands to new galaxies exploring the
exploring you know new worlds and and
uplifting humanity and and the rest of
the universe as a whole